here's the big news from project veritas
exclusive twitter all hands meeting from
june 16th the amazing thing is this
meeting just happened and then project
veritas is like we had the meeting
literally the moment and ended leaked
video of elon musk's address to twitter
employees about essential nature of free
speech voting republican and evolving
twitter quote i think it's essential to
have free speech musk said on the call
after describing his affinity for
twitter he added multiple opinions to
exist on twitter to make sure that we
are not sort of driving a narrative on
the call musk was asked about his
political leanings his plans for layoffs
in the direction of the company he
described himself as moderate noting
that he traditionally has voted democrat
by voter republican this week for the
first time in his life
he also discussed his vision for twitter
saying that traditional news media is
negative and they almost never get it
right he added that bots spam and
multi-account users must be contained i
think an important goal for twitter
would be to try to include as much of
the country as much of the world as
possible he knows that he's not hung up
on titles he reacted the news of project
veritas publishing the recorded meeting
on twitter by posting exactly in fact he
was responding to lydia that's right he
was i was so excited the guy from
project veritas actually called me i was
in target picking out a birthday card
and he's like what are you doing i was
like i'm picking out a birthday card
he's like oh so you didn't see that elon
musk tweeted at you and i was like
that's so cool i was freaking out in
target
so i can only imagine the woke twitter
employees who were lamenting libs of
tick-tock must be particularly irked
having to sit there and listen to elon
musk be like i think we should have free
speech and put wacky stuff on this
platform
did elon musk not know that it was being
recorded because if there's one meeting
and given the content of what was leaked
you would say certain things knowing
that it might be leaked afterwards
although this like is a great thing to
always just take for granted everyone's
recording everything you say at all
times so you don't say anything dumb
yeah uh shocking so shocking that you
have gavin newsom now looking for the
other free speech platform because they
they support free speech somewhere just
not where they don't want to hear it
that's so weird though it's like
yeah so that's another story we'll get
into but
what's the logic behind opposing free
speech or being you know california has
got a lot of skeletons in his closet
pertaining to big t it's california and
now it's like i'm going to go on truth
social
i i'm just wondering uh you know it's
it's amazing that they leak the meeting
right after it's done but oh those are
some good talking points
i think a very big one especially from
the corporate media's response to this
because according to their sources and
according to the twitter slack the
employees are very angry and they're
very pissed off and they don't know how
to deal with this larger acquisition
which they have voiced you know that
they were disappointed with so elon musk
just a few days ago even talked about
how twitter is biased against half the
country how they're inactive against
death threats against conservatives he
just voted for a conservative for the
first time in his life he also
hinted that he's going to be voting for
ron desantis in 2024 so obviously
what he said wasn't controversial but
for the people working at twitter for
the people in san francisco for the
yuppy starbucks drinking flip-flop
wearing yuppies there holy cow their
minds are probably going crazy and
they're freaking out because this is
this is the reckoning of a big social
media platform that's going to change
the game but this is funny the twitter
employees are outraged over this there
they've been complaining about elon
musk's takeover we have the leaked chats
where they're talking about banning libs
of tick tock and it's like they don't
seem to realize they are the snowflakes
in the avalanche of people like elon
musk voting republican it is the actions
they have taken with censorship with
their hostility and intolerance that's
resulting in elon musk being like i
don't think you're fun so i'm going to
vote for this other guy i'm going to go
read the babylon b they must be thinking
if only we banned the babylon b elon
musk would still vote democrat
what's encouraging about it is that
clearly not everyone within twitter is
so much on board with the nonsense and
it's it's a vocal minority who purport
to represent the majority uh and they're
going to find out at one point sooner
than later it's not going to be cool to
do this because people are going to want
an actual platform that actually just
allows people to talk not in hurtful
hate you know violent ways openly to
share ideas i gotta say truth social is
not bad
so when when i i ragged on it because
when they first launched i couldn't even
get in it and i was just like but they
what i mean by that is you know i don't
think i'm deserving of anything special
but i was reached out someone reached
out to me and they were like hey can we
get you on i was like sure and then i
couldn't get on i was like this is dom i
don't know what's going on like it's
just so disorganized and then someone
had at tim cast and it was like a parody
account and i was like i didn't care but
then i lost i i i heard it was like
number one in the app store and so i
checked and the engagement is crazy and
i was like whoa
people are on truth social and they're
having conversations
like more so than twitter
so i'm thinking to myself
if people use twitter because the
conversation's happening there but now
it's not and they're just trying to
destroy your life because you tweeted a
joke or retweeted a joke like dave
weigel at the washington post yo these
models would just be on truth social or
somewhere somewhere else i think elon
sees this as why he's desperately trying
to salvage this well elon made public
statements about this he said that it's
the failures failures of twitter that
led donald trump to create truth social
that it's bringing people there and it's
also he also makes the argument that
censorship is radicalizing individuals
as of course it's pushing people off to
further points of the internet it's now
not allowing a real honest discussion
it's it's making people's views uh be
double downed on instead of questioned
and that conversation used to happen on
twitter it's not anymore um and and
we're seeing again just the the
politicization that this kind of
radicalization of people from both
political parties that are are going
further and further from a way away from
each other and i think that's because of
big tech social media i think twitter
specifically i think twitter created
this rage cycle where
i knew i knew this guy i'm not gonna say
his name he's a reporter normal guy who
used to hang out
one day he he replied to donald trump
something like oh shut up and he got
like a 100 retweets oh he went from
having a couple hundred followers to
having a thousand followers
oh the dude destroyed his life and
career he became a trump reply guy
and then he ended up getting you know
tens of thousands of followers and i
said yeah but who's gonna hire you now
what are those followers good for but it
felt good it was an addiction
no that's it that's what people did they
drove themselves off a cliff
no i don't have a truth handle yet maybe
i'll uh have to look if the engagement
and the discussion is there it's uh but
i i actually as far as twitter goes i
enjoy the discussion and the engagement
with people with whom i disagree
ideologically it's the amazing thing
about uh sharing ideas and and
fighting in the political sense
well gavin's there now so oh
i still enjoy picking on gavin on
twitter but he he has yet to recognize
you know what i really like doing is i
like responding to far leftists but in
agreement so it's like
they'll tweet something that i agree
with and i'll make sure i'm going to
respond with an agreement or adding to
their point because that's my point i'm
like i don't hate him you're like i'm
not just going to respond to someone for
the sake of being like you're wrong
about that one i'm going to respond
specifically only when i think they're
right about something and then it's
funny how their friends react and
they're like
you know no tim pool should not be
agreeing with us and i'm like well you
know i do so
do something about it i guess it's the
super double reverse uh cancellation if
you agree with the people then their
friends have to cancel them oh yeah
and there's something i call bugs
bunnying you know you know how bugs
bunny did the duck season rabbit season
back and forth you know that bit mm-hmm
you know there's one uh all right so you
got don you got daffy duck and you got
bugs bunny and daffy is saying it's
rabbit season and pulling the sign off
the tree and then bugs says it's duck
season and pulls a sign off the tree and
elmer fudd is standing there like who am
i gonna shoot because he's a hunter and
then bugs at the last minute flips it
and he goes it's rabbit season and then
daffy goes no no no it's duck season and
then bugs goes if you say so then elmer
fudd shoots daffy instead so when you
agree with them
they have to disagree with you if
they're tribalists so then all of a
sudden you'll find these like
progressives on the side of the fascists
or whatever because you know do robert
do we know like is elon gonna get the
company for a lesser price have they
resolved the bought issue yet that has
not been resolved and so we'll see i
mean the question is what happens to
truth if elon musk takes over twitter
and really returns it to its free speech
what do you think chris i think that you
have a completely different audience on
on truth than you do on on twitter i
think these are completely different two
different audiences and i don't think
there's much overlap in it so when
if elon ever does get a hold of twitter
i think that audience is already gone
and they were never they're never coming
back i agree i think i think it might be
too late i think the segmentation of
these platforms is upon us yeah i mean
donald trump even said if he gets
invited back on twitter he's not going
to come back because he has truth social
but there also has been accusations
against truth social with censorship
against people posting january 6th
information that's some of the alleged
information coming out within the last
couple days and there is something as
barnes as you brought up to the larger
point of if twitter does take over uh
and allow free speech on their platform
people are saying it's predominantly
going to affect donald trump and truth
social the most out of all the other
platforms well i think that's where
there needs to be what rumble is doing
is the right way to go which is to
create clear transparent open roles
honestly getter kind of didn't well i
won't be critical of anyone else just
say no one else has created the rules
that rumble is going about creating not
only creating those rules but also
creating a participatory process whereby
consumers and creators can be part of
that process create rules that can be
open source that can be mimicked and
mirrored and copied by getter by truth
by gab by
anyone else by twitter if elon musk
purchase it and because these are rules
are designed to reach a balance between
not making it a troll heavy platform but
at the same time making it as free for
speech and expression as possible that
heresy and dissident speech is allowed
and that's what people wanted in the
original free and open internet and
rumble's been taking the lead at
creating open transparent rules to make
that a reality thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there